au coeur de l'industrie pétrochimique du
canada les certitudes gagne du terrain
la communauté de sarnia en ontario
craint un bouleversement et la secousse
pourrait venir de son voisin immédiat
l'état du michigan
ici pétrole les pipelines sont au coeur
de l'activité économique dans cet
atelier
les travailleurs sont sur le qui vive
l'économie pourrait s'écrouler sous nos
pieds dit ce soudeur de pipelines comme
son père et son grand père avant lui la
raison en raison une question adressée à
la gouverneure démocrate du michigan
gretchen rythme mènent une lutte
acharnée pour fermer la canalisation 5
dan bridge une promesse électorale
elle a ordonné l'arrêt de l'oléoduc qui
traverse son état pour le 12 mai sa
crainte
un bris de la portion sous-marine du
pipeline qui pourrait entraîner une
catastrophe environnementale dans les
grands lacs
la canalisation vieille de plus de 65
ans transporte 540 mille baril de
pétrole brut léger et de gaz naturel
chaque jour vers l'est du canada une
infrastructure vitale qui fournit 40 à
50 % du pétrole aux raffineries
ontarienne et québécoise
la pression augmente sur justin trudeau
la fermeture de la canalisation 5
pourrait entraîner la perte de milliers
d'emplois des deux côtés de la frontière
prévient ottawa en coulisses le
gouvernement canadien
alors c'est une offensive diplomatique
qui rappelle la stratégie entourant la
renégociation de l'alena
c'est parmi les plus grands prix en est
que nous avons dans notre nos
discussions avec l'administration en ce
moment
l'enjeu a été soulevé dans les plus
hautes sphères à washington auprès du
président maiden de hauts responsables
de la maison blanche et des élus d'états
américains qui dépendent aussi du
pipeline pour leurs besoins énergétiques
l'ambassadrice canadienne est en contact
direct avec la gouverneure du michigan
avec un jeu souligne vraiment le fait
que cette infrastructure est essentielle
pour le canada pour l'ontario pour
québec mais aussi dans le sa région le
canada et enbridge milite pour la
construction de tunnels sous les grands
lacs pour réduire les risques de
déversements en à gauche moi l'enjeu est
non négociable martèle le ministre des
ressources naturelles et le gouvernement
trudeau marche sur des oeufs
le canada a vu éviter de froisser un
président avec qui il a promis de
coopérer pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
joe biden qui a signé l'arrêt de mort de
l'oléoduc keystone xl à son arrivée à la
maison blanche ne semble pas pressé
d'intervenir mais en même temps et
recrée nes qui est certaine forme
d'énergie qui vont être nécessaires pour
des générations
selon l'ambassadrice la fermeture de la
canalisation 5 le 12 mai est improbable
alors que la bataille entre enbridge et
le michigan est maintenant devant les
tribunaux américains
ottawa pourrait intervenir en
brandissant un vieux traité canado
américain qui limite les gestes
unilatéraux en matière d'énergie et dans
sa bataille devant les tribunaux
la gouverneure 8 me à des alliés sept
leaders autochtones américaine souligne
que sa communauté dépend des revenus de
la pêche sur les grands lacs
elle craint l'impact d'un déversement et
les effets de la construction d'un
tunnel sur l'écosystème
il faut éviter de perpétuer notre
dépendance envers les énergies fossiles
fait elle valoir
où
mais de l'autre côté de la frontière
pour les travailleurs de sarnia il n'y a
pas que les questions environnementales
qui doivent peser dans la balance
il y à aussi leur gagne pain le soudeur
en john sting créé pour ce métier qu'il
pratique depuis 24 ans c'est un art et
j'en suis très fier ce serait triste que
cela nous soit enlevé un sentiment
d'impuissance face à un litige ou si
complexe un conflit qui semble si près
et si loin à la fois
[Musique]